today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
welcome to the show yesterday was day
three out of four of the republican
national convention we're going to look
at pictures we're going to look at clips
i'm going to give you sort of my
thoughts on
uh how i would characterize the themes
of days one two and three so far and
will predict the final night tonight but
i i have to say and i think
some other people in the audience are
feeling this way as well especially
people who have been with me
on the live streams nightly i'm
exhausted from this nonsense
and you the the dnc last week was sort
of tiring because
you know i tend to start work on each
day's show relatively early in the
morning and so when it's 9 to 11 p.m and
sometimes it goes 10 minutes late
and then people want me to keep talking
about what we saw
they're just long days so that's that's
like the normal tiredness but the rnc in
particular
is emotionally exhausting because it's
just
constant lies and delusions and
depravity and diabolical claims and
so on and so forth so i'm very much
looking for it to be over and i think
our vacation in a couple of weeks
is going to be a much needed one but
let's look at what happened yesterday so
the keynote yesterday was vice president
mike pence
and there was a big build up to mike
pence karen pence his wife spoke earlier
and they had a big crowd and incredibly
if you didn't know a pandemic was going
on
you certainly wouldn't have noticed it
from watching the speech we have a few
different pictures you'll see mike pence
after the speech kind of walking down
and fist-bumping and high-fiving people
nobody's wearing a mask everybody on top
of each other from news reports nobody
who was there was tested for
coronavirus donald trump himself also
because he just can't stay away from
any day of this uh convention
showed up and came out at fort mchenry
in baltimore maryland
after mike pence's speech and he was
right up near people and
again you know we're outdoors the
transmission possibility is lower but
you're talking about hundreds of people
here and then
of course mathematically you start to it
becomes more and more likely that
somebody's going to get the virus if
they're hanging around each other
donald trump they're right up on people
uh and then as you can see
just not a mask in sight maybe somebody
was wearing a mask but from all the
different angles all the different video
and pictures that we have of the event
it did not appear as though anybody
anybody was wearing a mask
people were sitting relatively close
together it was like there was no
pandemic going on so i tweeted yesterday
how many cases do you think
this event will be ultimately
responsible for
most people thought the number was
certainly more than zero but it remains
to be seen and again it's the optics
it's the optics of pretending and acting
like everything is normal
now in terms of the themes of the three
republican national convention days so
far
day one here's the way i see it
day one was unhinged screaming right
like
upper screaming outrageous
sort of like amphetamine day where you
had don junior out of control
sw eyes almost completely swollen shut
we'll talk about that later he's denied
that the entire
thing was fueled by cocaine you had don
junior's girlfriend kimberly guilfoyle
reminiscent of north korean propaganda a
screaming speech
day two i would kind of call downer day
where it was really a very
boring down day capped by melania
trump's very low-key almost
unenthusiastic
support of donald trump and indeed if
you've been following what's been going
on with the two of them for the last
four years she may not be enthusiastic
about donald trump getting reelected
and then day three last night i think
was the dangerous day where you're going
to see
the types of claims that were made not
just by mike pence but by other speakers
were the types of claims that could
certainly move people to real world
violence so let's look at a
couple of different things one cutesy
little idea that has been now
it's just become popular as a trope
during the rnc
is claiming joe biden and democrats are
going to cancel and end stuff remember
they're going to end the suburbs was a
popular one
here is a senator joni ernst who is
potentially going to be removed from the
senate we can hope
saying that if you elect joe biden he's
going to ban animal agriculture and he's
also going to
eliminate gas-powered vehicles if given
power
they would essentially ban animal
agriculture
and eliminate gas-powered cars now
of course this is not true the truth is
that joe biden does have noam chomsky
agrees
i've looked at it and i don't know how
anyone could come to any other
conclusion joe biden does have
the most progressive climate platform of
any
would-be president if joe biden is
elected that will be the most
progressive climate platform and yes it
has aggressive
goals for phasing out the internal
combustion engine which i
am in favor of it has aggressive goals
for reducing emissions from animal
agriculture but cows aren't going to be
banned stakes aren't going to be banned
and at no time anytime soon are
gas-powered vehicles going to be banned
another speaker going from senator joni
ernst to senator marsha blackburn from
tennessee who is a long-time republican
bomb thrower
she suggests that what democrats want to
do
is to keep coronavirus lockdowns going
so long
that it will force people into a
dependency on the government i guess she
imagines if you keep people locked up
eventually they'll need the government
to bring them food
they'll need the government to bring the
medicine whatever the case may be
a crazy uh uh
sort of exaggeration of uh what
small government people claim the left
wants to do but she said it take a look
if the democrats had their way they
would keep you locked
in your house until you become dependent
on the government
then we also heard as the nepotism
continued
from eric trump's wife lara trump
and one of the funniest themes from her
speech and from others like
a former football player jess owens and
some others was the idea that
the democratic party are
leftist coastal elites
when the entire trump family and most of
their spouses are
actually these coastal elites that they
decry here is lara trump talking about
when she met the trump family
saying they are hard workers and really
down to earth any of those
words never fully weighed on me until i
met my husband
and the trump family any preconceived
notion i had of this family
disappeared immediately they were warm
and caring
they were hard workers and they were
down to earth
they reminded me of my own family they
made me feel like i was home
walking the halls of the trump
organization i saw the same family
environment
i also saw the countless women
executives who thrived there
year after year sort of like opposite
day like that that is the exact opposite
of what the trump family is
they brought in former football coach
lou holtz
who claims that joe biden isn't really
religious
and this is actually really interesting
so let's take a look at the clip
the biden harris ticket is the most
radically pro-abortion campaign in
history
they another politicians are catholics
in name only and abandon innocent lives
so i've been talking about this a lot
lately including during the streams
because joe biden is the religious
candidate now i don't care about a
candidate's religion
i want religion completely separate from
governance i don't believe an
individual's religion
should play any kind of role in what the
law should be
etc secularism doesn't mean people can't
be religious
in their private lives as a matter of
pride of their own
you know personal conviction but it
should play no role in governance
donald trump is probably not religious
at all donald trump is probably one of
the least religious presidents we've
ever had doesn't make him a good
president i don't care
biden's the religious guy i'm not
religious i prefer biden because he'd be
a better president
but now they are going further because
nominally
everybody knows joe biden is a catholic
they now have to step it up and say
joe biden only claims to be a catholic
he's not really religious which is the
exact type of mind reading
that when we say that person seems
racist based on their actions
the right says you don't know what's
really in their mind
this is exactly the type of argument
they're making to claim
of course without evidence that trump is
the religious candidate and biden
it really is not because he's lying
about his catholic faith
notice that it's an argument they have
said is a bad argument when it comes to
racist beliefs
with religious beliefs they're
comfortable saying biden's not actually
the religious guy
again bringing up this idea of law and
order and
how trump will stop chaos in the streets
take a look at that
last week joe biden didn't say one word
about the violence and chaos engulfing
cities across this country
so let me be clear the violence must
stop
whether in minneapolis portland or
kenosha
too many heroes have died defending our
freedom
to see americans strike each other down
we will have
law and order on the streets of this
country for every american
of every race and creed and color
now what is dangerous about this is
they are pointing to chaos in the
streets now now again
protests have mostly been peaceful um
most of the people who have actually
committed violence
are are don't actually appear to be
protesters they appear to be other
things we're going to talk of course
about kyle rittenhouse momentarily but
it's a very strange argument to make
that things are crazy in the streets
right now
after trump's been president for four
years so you should re-elect donald
trump so he can stop the craziness in
the streets that doesn't really
that doesn't make any sense but it
doesn't matter to them and that's what's
so dangerous about this
on coronavirus mike pence talking about
how
um the uh uh on coronavirus
we are actually a country of miracles
and it's not unreasonable to expect a
miracle to help us with coronavirus
which is just
unbelievably wild listen to mike pence
say it here
now last week joe biden said
that no miracle is coming
well what joe doesn't seem to understand
is that america is a nation of miracles
and i'm proud to report that we're on
track to have the world's first
safe effective coronavirus vaccine by
the end of this year
so what mike pence doesn't mention there
is that
other countries have already dealt with
coronavirus and they didn't have
miracles they just did the stuff that
our public health officials recommend
mike pence goes into this very strange
rant about
miracles and this is a country of
miracles and we're maybe we're going to
get a miracle
other countries have already dealt with
the virus successfully many countries
they didn't have miracles they had masks
and social distancing and keeping things
closed until it's safe to open them
then again mike pence as an
accomplishment
touting veterans choice as an
accomplishment of the trump
administration
this was an obama law from 2014.
president trump kept his word again
we reformed the va and veterans choice
is now available for every veteran in
america
so it used to be just donald trump who
when asked what are your big
accomplishments he would say well
veterans choice is one
and of course it's not an accomplishment
of his it's a barack obama
accomplishment now mike pence jumping
into that as well
and then mike pence also a bragging
about opening up america's schools
and we're not just opening up america
again
we're opening up america's schools
the degree to which he says this like a
badge of honor
confirms to us that the science doesn't
matter
it's just the optics of saying we're
opening schools despite what the left
wants as i told you yesterday
thousands tens of thousands of cases
already
at a variety of colleges and
universities that have opened
problems in high schools and elementary
schools it's an absolute and total
disaster
and then lastly this is sort of the
epitome of what they are running on
mike pence uses the slogan make america
great again but he has to modify it take
a look
the land and with president donald trump
in the white house
for four more years and with god's help
we will make america great again
again
thank you god bless you
right so if you're still trying to make
america great again
after four years it proves you didn't do
it in the four that you got
so now they are sort of trying to take
advantage of coronavirus by saying
we did make america great again then we
had coronavirus
and we're going to make america great
again a second time
the rhetoric yesterday is the type of
rhetoric that i'm worried
is going to lead to violence from
trumpists
if trump loses by a small margin claims
it was rigged
it is the exact type of rhetoric that
will lead to real world violence and we
need to talk now about the polling
because some of my fellow leftists are
getting a little bit
off the rails on this issue okay i'm
finding myself
very annoyed by a portion of the left
that thinks anybody being cautious
about the polling for donald trump
versus joe biden
is doing some kind of reverse
gaslighting or concern trolling
i am here to tell you guys right now cut
it
we we have to stop it or we're going to
lose donald trump can easily end up
winning re-election now when i say this
i'm not saying trump is definitely
winning right now despite the polling
i'm not saying
the polling is wrong what i am saying is
that a small
change between now and november could
easily end up with donald trump winning
the electoral college while still losing
the popular vote
every time i point this out i get more
and more people emailing me saying david
stop reverse gaslighting us you're
making us think biden will lose
so that we go out and vote when in
reality biden has this locked up
first of all joe biden does not have
this locked up and i'm going to present
the facts to you let's do it step by
step
number one national polling trend lines
yes joe biden right now is winning the
national polls by an average of seven
but two days ago it was eight and two
months ago it was ten
so the lead is shrinking for joe biden
now
okay you might say fine joe biden's
winning by seven instead of ten
but 7 is a huge lead in the popular vote
well that's true
but let me remind you that on this day
in 2016
you go back and look at the polling
trump versus hillary
august 27 2016 hillary was winning by
6.3
so the difference between today and 2016
is 0.7 points biden's plus seven right
now
hillary four years ago today was plus
6.3
and trump won electorally in 2016.
i don't know about you but 0.7 points is
not exactly
something that makes me feel
particularly confident if it comes down
to 0.7 percentage points
in november 3rd comparing 2016 to 2020
like for example hillary won the popular
vote by 2.1
if biden wins by 2.8 he can still lose
he can still lose so this is not a joke
this is not gas lighting
this is not concerned trolling and
posters are noticing
538's nate silver tweeted about it
yesterday he tweeted quote
biden's electoral college win
probability down a bit to 70 percent
after some mediocre polls for him this
morning he had been hovering around 73
percent so not a big shift
but worth a quick twitter thread and
nate silver went on later in the same
thread to say quote
biden has gotten some not so spectacular
swing state polls lately
his lead in florida is down to 5.4 and
pennsylvania to 5.8 which
remained the most likely tipping point
states not bad
but the electoral college popular vote
gap would appear
to be widening a bit and then later
yesterday nate silver tweeted quote
fundamentally the fundamentals are
improving for trump
the economy is getting better although
that could be threatened by
congressional inaction
covid cases are going down although that
could reverse itself at pretty much any
time
this is exactly the case i've been
making for two to three months now
presidential prognosticator alan
lichtman recently said
all of his qualitative uh uh indicators
point to biden
it still looks okay for biden so what
do you want to take a chance on that and
then add to this
voter suppression that we know they will
do the funny business with the post
office that they are doing already
early voting starts soon you should go
do it
find your plan are you going to vote in
person
are you going to wear you know three
masks and a hazmat suit and vote in
person
are you going to get an absentee ballot
and send it in by mail
are you getting an absentee ballot and
dropping it off have a plan
we must operate under the assumption
that trump could win
any state by one vote and based on that
every single person should be voting and
assuming nothing this is not concern
trolling
these are the numbers let me know what
you think i'm on twitter at deepakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman
davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
8 bucks a month and you get the entire
library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
okay you can participate in uh
respectful political discussions
on the david pakman show subreddit at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t a few interesting posts
i spotted this morning there is a new
poll
which um uh indicates that
50 of americans believe joe biden
is too liberal what i think is really
interesting about this is that you
right now have completely opposite
claims being made about joe biden the
right
every day this week at the republican
national convention has been insisting
that if joe biden wins
he will affect his socialist marxist
ideology on the country
and we won't have capitalism and right
you understand the way that that goes
the progressive left meanwhile is
displeased that joe biden is not really
very left
now what's the truth there is some
empirical reality here and the empirical
reality is
that joe biden generally speaking is a
center-left candidate
who as a sign of the times because it's
2020
and not 2012 or 2008 or 1993 as some
people like to point to when they talk
about joe biden's beliefs
joe biden has adopted elements of what
bernie sanders
wants on uh climate and the economy
of what aoc would like to see in the
green new deal and so
in the broader global context if you
have put biden on a political spectrum
that includes europe for example
biden is center-left-ish and if you
compare
biden's platforms to those of previous
american presidents
he is the most progressive on a bunch of
issues
but that doesn't mean that much when you
compare him to people like hillary
clinton
and barack obama etc that's the reality
somehow half the country thinks biden is
too far left that tells you a little bit
about how the united states compares
politically to many other parts of the
world
user karaoke 23 asked
after posting some videos of some
protests how are these people going to
react if trump loses
i am going to address this in detail on
tomorrow's program and i'm going to look
at
which electoral scenario in november is
the most likely to lead to violence
and who is likely to be doing the
violence i don't believe it's hyperbolic
to be thinking about it i don't believe
it's hyperbolic to be concerned about it
i think there is a real possibility for
violence
and listen i'm going to be talking about
kyle rittenhouse the 17 year old who
started shooting people in wisconsin
okay
the violence is already happening and i
think it's quite possible donald trump
will weaponize and coalesce
um that more of that violence depending
on the results
lastly user knife edger asks is jimmy
from philly for real
i just listened to the segment on
david's youtube channel until recently i
genuinely thought this was a real guy
with real delusions
but segments like this make me wonder is
this a character
i'm new here but i'm sure this question
gets asked all the time on this
um subreddit i am here to tell you
jimmy from philly is very real it is not
a character that he is playing and i
know that
we often wonder sometimes people are so
out there
that it's a natural question to say is
this a character how can someone like
this even get through the day how can
someone like this survive into adulthood
quite frankly but jimmy from philly is
real he is a trumpist he is a furious
trumpist
and um there is every indication
that he is completely genuine in the
beliefs he espouses and that's a very
scary thing because as i said before
even if trump loses in november we will
still have
more than 60 million people who will
have voted for trump and that's
something we will have to deal with
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit more than uh 20 000 of you have
subscribed
over on reddit making us one of the
largest progressive media
subreddits on the internet an incredible
accolade
okay we have to talk we have to talk
about the situation in kenosha wisconsin
where 17 year old kyle rittenhouse has
uh now been arrested for murder
after shooting people in what is
sort of an amalgam of the worst of the
worst
of american culture gun culture uh
reactionary culture
uh police uh uh sort of um i'm not
actually i'm not talking about police
but i'm talking about people like the
shooter who
sort of uh idolize and deify uh put
police-like figures
and uh want to be out there with
firearms
affecting what they believe to be some
kind of
uh militia or or
gatekeeping i i don't even know what to
call it but the
where i want to start is that what is
very clearly
um colloquially speaking murder it will
be up to the legal system to determine
if it is
legally legal murder right guilt of
murder but what is what is colloquially
speaking murder
we are starting to see right-wing media
um
implicitly or explicitly defend the
actions of 17 year old kyle rittenhouse
and i want to start with a clip from
last night's tucker carlson program on
fox news
take a look at this so we're really
surprised that looting and arson
accelerated to murder how shocked are we
that 17 year olds with rifles decided
they had to maintain order
when no one else would everyone could
see what was happening
in kenosha it was getting crazier by the
hour
so the the argument that's being made
to sort of indirectly defend the actions
of this kid
are that listen if you have chaos in the
streets
and nobody else deals with it then it's
natural that
a 17 year old gun toter is going to
start policing the streets
even if you grant which i don't
that there is some problem at the
country level
of the streets being out of control
remember
overall crime has been on the decline
for a long time in the united states
even if you were to grant that which i
don't
the idea that it's natural for
gun-toting 17-year-olds to be the ones
policing the streets is absolute and
complete
lunacy now coverage of this event if you
compare it to other events
has been unfortunately the worst of the
worst that we could get from right-wing
media
and even from so-called uh uh
independent independent media from
so-called nonpartisan media
remember for example um
that the jacob blake story was
widely reported on just a couple of days
prior and if you look at for example two
new york post tweets which we are
putting up on the screen for you on the
left the new york post tweeting about
jacob blake who was killed by police
jacob blake had a knife in his car when
he was shot by police
on the right the same new york post
with a picture of kyle rittenhouse
cleaning graffiti tweets suspected
teen gunman kyle rittenhouse
spotted cleaning kenosha graffiti before
the shooting now no mention of the fact
that
in wisconsin the minimum age to open
carry
is 18 so shooting aside
what kyle rittenhouse was doing was
against the law but of course
i guess nobody stopped him to say hey
what state are you from
and what age are you and is it even
legal for you to be here with this gun
remember that when trayvon martin was
killed by george zimmerman he was 17
years old
corporate media of course the right was
very quick to immediately say
he was 17 but this this guy was an adult
he was a big aggressive guy
and he's really an adult and he should
have he should be considered one in his
interaction with george zimmerman and
yet here
you have a gun-toting 17-year-old white
kid
also 17 at like trayvon martin
but this one's a kid who was cleaning
graffiti and anyway like tucker carlson
says
if the streets are out of control isn't
it natural for gun-toting 17-year-olds
to be out there policing
this is crazy this is crazy now we have
now
retrospectively found out that this kid
kyle rittenhouse i i maybe shouldn't
even be saying this kid he's 17
and you know the legal system will
determine how he should be he should be
dealt with
uh about two hours before the first
shooting
um he was actually interviewed written
house was
at a kenosha vehicle dealership by some
guy who was live streaming what was
going on in kenosha take a look at this
we're protecting from the citizens and i
just got pepper sprayed by a
person in the crowd so you had
non-lethal but
you just respond we don't have
non-lethal
so you guys are full-on ready to defend
the property yes we are
now if i can ask can you guys step back
medical ems right here
then we had another interview with kyle
rittenhouse who spoke to
richie mcginnis who's a video editor at
the daily caller a right-wing news and
opinion site
and again just stumbling across this
gun-toting 17 year old take a look what
are you doing out here obviously you're
armed and uh you're in front of this
business we saw burning last night so
what's up so people are getting injured
and
our job is to protect this business and
part of my job is to also help people if
there's somebody hurt
i'm running into harm's way that's why i
have my rifle because i need to protect
myself obviously
but also my med kit now i i think that
there's a few different things
there's a bunch of stories here one
story as i've already pointed out
is the immediate media narratives that
are created
white kid with the gun it's just a kid
it's natural that he was out there he's
a good kid he was cleaning graffiti etc
uh even jacob blake immediately
oh well there was a knife in his car
did was that did police know that at the
time uh there's you know claims about
well there was a
there was a phone call the police may
have suspected et cetera but the
handling of these two
is completely different and that's one
storyline
the other storyline is this broader
narrative aside from this particular
case
it's the broader narrative of
republicans for months now have been
harping on
the streets are out of control joe biden
wants to defund the police which he
doesn't
everything is going to go completely
haywire if joe biden is elected
we need the second amendment and joe
biden wants to take it away
and then after all of that this kid
goes out and he actually sort of does
what would naturally follow
remember the concept of stochastic
terrorism from months and months of
republicans and trump and the rnc
pushing this exact story now the truth
is that very few of the deaths
linked to protests uh have been a result
of
violence by protesters that's really
really important to understand because
the rhetoric from trump and the
conservative movement
have been painting the picture that
protesters protesting against police
brutality
have gone out there and attacked people
and killed people etc
the reality is that some of these
violent events have been
linked to movements like the boogaloo
movement which is a right-wing movement
that wants to generate a second civil
war
if you look at reviews of the different
deaths that have been linked to
protests many of them are either
unrelated or
unclear if they are related micron
blanchard was shot on may 31st in
riverside illinois
by an unknown assailant in an incident
apparently unrelated to protests but
it's wrapped in as part of the protest
violence
uh david macady shot on june 1st
in louisville macady ran a barbecue
store was shot and killed by members of
the national guard
when he apparently fired at them with a
handgun
the david dorn situation from june 2nd
in saint louis dorne is this retired
police officer
allegedly shot and killed by stefan
cannon
as dorne was responding to a lot an
alarm at a friend's
business in an area where looting was
reportedly happening
uh again it's not the protesters that
are out there
doing even a lot of the violence that is
reported on
so what's dangerous about this is that
when you combine this with the rhetoric
from the rnc
and from trump and the imagery and
claims that joe biden is going to let
crime run rampant
defund the police which he doesn't want
to do so on and so forth
what else do you expect so kyle
rittenhouse
has personal responsibility here the
legal system is going to adjudicate that
for sure
and yet we also can't ignore without
absolving any him of any responsibility
the environment in which this is all
being ginned up
and we have to think about what this is
going to look like on november 4th
if donald trump loses by a small margin
and that is a real concern which i'm
going to talk about tomorrow
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show we'll
have more coverage of this upcoming
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the
show just for members sign up today
at joinpackman.com coupon code saves you
40
vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
today i'm joined by maya dukemaseva
who's a senior writer at the chicago
reader she covers policing
housing the courts and local social
justice movements
maya it's great to speak to you today
thanks for having me on
so there are so many conversations over
the last four or five months that
relate to policing in the united states
we've had the george floyd
protests we've had sort of more
political conflicts between local state
and federal law enforcement as we saw
federal troops deployed to certain
cities around the united states
one of the things that is sort of
underlying a lot of these conversations
are uh the issues of police unions as
well as
uh police immunity in certain situations
and it's interesting maybe as a place to
start the conversation to think about a
lot of people who tend to be in favor of
democratization of workplaces and in
favor of unions and collective
bargaining
have identified that police unions are a
little bit different that it's not
exactly the same when you're talking
about a union
maybe of delivery drivers and a union
for police officers can you talk a
little bit about
structurally what the differences are
yeah police unions are very different
from a lot of
other public sector unions or
private sector unions so the i think the
key difference begins
with where the power dynamic lies
between the workers and the bosses
so police officers are employed by a
municipality
and basically unlike any other type of
worker
it's police that are respon
the the municipality depends on the
police for the protection
of property and a certain kind of status
quo
so historically police officers have
been this
the strike force against striking
striking workers in other sectors
they have been the uh vehicles for
maintaining segregation
and other types of policies around that
that politicians in the city would want
to
perpetuate so the in the state of
illinois like in a lot of other places
uh police officers and firefighters as
well actually
are prohibited from striking and so when
they sit down to bargain
with their employer which is the city
they
both sides know that the the strike is
not on the table
however there's other ways that cops can
kind of
withhold their labor and be
non-cooperative
to get the kind of contracts they would
like from the city
and the city unlike and you know let's
say like a private
you know steel mill operator or uh
you know uh i don't know any other type
of private business owner
or manager there's there's like limited
there's limited ways that uh that kind
of withholding of the labor by the
police officers
can be mitigated so you can't you know
you can't easily bring in scabs
essentially to to fill in the gap that's
left by striking workers or
workers they're withholding their labor
in some way so really what we see time
and again
um and i'm specifically especially in
chicago is
the municipality is sort of like they're
really at the mercy of the union in this
in the sense and historically this is
why municipalities were so
uh resistant to having police unions
because
the kind of view of local officials and
also
of federal judges that litigated you
know decided over lawsuits over
uh police unionization throughout the
20th century was that
police officers really aren't workers
like other types of workers
they are a paramedic military
organization
and just like the military they have to
have their one allegiance be
to their employer to the state that they
serve and they shouldn't have any other
type of
uh you know interest involved in this
and so now that police officers are able
to unionize
it's it's really a dynamic in which
they're able to
get a lot more in their contracts and
get a lot more concessions and a lot
more
bargain from a much stronger position
than any other really public or private
sector
uh workforce is this where the uh
unions were able to sort of gain enough
leverage
to develop some of the defaults that are
in place now
in terms of immunity or is that actually
coming from some other structure
yeah so there's as far as the um
again and i know specifics about the the
police contracts in chicago so really
i'm speaking from
from from this place yeah but the a lot
of the
the first the very first police union
contract that police officers in chicago
had which came in 1980
really started at with its bedrock being
the
the policeman's bill of rights which uh
was modeled on the
kind of first amendment bill of rights
type of protections that developed for
criminal suspects and
and people accused of crimes in the u.s
constitution in the in the 20th century
and so as that was happening in the
mid-century police officers who were
increasingly accused of misconduct that
were increasingly
dealing with harsher and hearts or
discipline from municipalities
they developed a sort of view that the
police need a bill of rights and they
need protections when they're accused of
some kind of brutality or misconduct
and so the bedrock of the contract here
in chicago has always been this bill of
rights that protects officers from
having to make statements about
uh their behavior on the job in a
certain constraint of time
they're able to know who is accusing
them of their crimes they're able to
coordinate with one another before they
give statements they're able to amend
their statements after
video or audio evidence about the
incident becomes available
so really the core of the contract is
about protecting officers who are
accused of some kind of misconduct and
beyond that there's a lot of other
things like
uh provisions that would require
destruction of misconduct records
there's all kinds of stuff obviously
that's more on the labor side of things
about
hours and overtime and vacation and all
of that uh but basically
yeah the the contract is is now
extremely elaborate
and uh it really it's really
much more um there's much more that off
every time there's something new that's
in the contract which also
of course depends on the political
situation in which the contract is
decided
every time something new is added it's
much more difficult to take it away
and to to renegotiate the contract so
what we see time after time is
especially throughout the 90s the
contract becomes more elaborate there's
there's more and more protections and
guarantees for officers
and less and less space for the city to
come in and really radically change
things in order to
say change how officers are disciplined
for example
so in this context when the um defund
the police
uh movement i guess if we call it that
uh got
some momentum a few months ago one of
the things that that i
said was i'm unsure that defund
is the right approach in in all cases
and that there
are uh but my this is just to give you
context for the upcoming discussion
my thought was there there are cases
where there's too much funding for
certain things like militarization of
police there's other cases where
actually
being underfunded leads to some of the
sort of lower hanging fruit policing
that actually causes the problems we're
trying to solve anyway my point was
i laid out some ideas that i think would
be very useful in actually getting at
some of the problems in policing which
include for example a national bad
actors database to
take away the possibility of a police
officer leaving one department for
uh bad actions being hired elsewhere in
the new department saying we had no idea
there was no way we could have known
that that's what
that that's what took place that this
individual had a bad
uh act in their past now the obvious
obstacle to that would be every police
union would oppose such a database right
i mean is it is it is it even
conceivable that something like that
could get past
unions yeah so every
every police union would oppose that and
also in a lot of places
the police the contracts do actually
provide for the destruction of police
misconduct records
after a certain amount of years wow so
even if you
were wanted to create such a database in
a lot of places you just couldn't
because the records wouldn't
even exist anymore i mean illinois is
really an exceptional case because we've
had a lot of civil rights litigation on
this issue
and basically this past june actually
the illinois
supreme court decided on a case that was
um launched that was started by
a uh independent journalist and civil
rights activist jamie calvin
in calvin versus chicago the illinois
supreme court decided that
the destruction of police misconduct
records
which were it turned out that the city
wasn't doing it
even though the police union contract
said that they were supposed to be
destroying them after five years
turned out they weren't doing it we've
got records going back to the 60s
and the illinois supreme court found
that
actually it's a dead lottery provision
in the police union contract that these
records can't and shouldn't be destroyed
because it's a matter of public interest
to continue having them
so technically like in the state of
illinois you could
have uh some kind of statewide database
where like
if a cop gets fired which by the way is
extremely extremely rare
for a cop to even have any kind of
discipline uh based on misconduct
allegations or complaints
but in the rare occasions where they are
disciplined or fired
you know you could technically have this
kind of database that would prevent them
from them going across to a different
municipality and and getting a job there
but i think that one of the other things
and kind of brought this up with your
earlier question about
about the immunity that that officers
have
that the kind of uh immunity from
prosecution for their conduct on the job
what's sometimes called uh qualified
immunity
or indemnification that stuff doesn't
really stem
from the union contracts themselves
those are provisions that are
installed by state law so it's the state
that indemnifies officers
against uh essentially liability for the
things they do on the job which is then
why whenever a cop uh
you know does something bad they are
it's the city that has to be responsible
for that conduct it's the city that gets
sued it's the city that has to pay
and now the conversation that i'm
hearing more and more is about how we
should actually require officers
to carry liability insurance of some
sort for misconduct like sort of like
malpractice insurance for doctors
uh so that they are themselves
financially liable
for their behavior and then if they
mess up enough times then no nobody's
going to want to insure them and that's
how you get
these kind of quote-unquote bad apples
out of the force
well that conversation is really dead in
the water as long as there are these
state laws indemnifying officers and on
doing them would be like
a massive massive battle especially in a
state like illinois where
you know it's very blue up in chicago
but then the rest of state is pretty red
it would be hard to get republican state
legislation on board for
changing the significant indemnification
thing
but yeah that's just an additional layer
of complication
aside from the contract that already
provides so many protections for
officers
let's pause our conversation there with
maya duke massive
and we will have the full conversation
for you on our youtube channel at
youtube.com
the david pakman show the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow great perks and benefits
as well read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so we're sort of looking forward to or
at least i am more so than i was looking
forward to the conventions to the
debates between donald trump and joe
biden which are scheduled starting in
the later part of september i believe
we're going to be covering all of them
live for sure
um one of the things that i've said is
that
if you are expecting that joe biden is
going to implode and he's going to just
be unable to get anything out and and so
on and so forth
you're probably going to be underwhelmed
and in fact one of the things that i've
been pointing to
were some of the expectations when the
democratic primary
was down to only bernie sanders and joe
biden you had a bunch of people on the
right and even some people on the left
kind of in the pro-bernie crowd who were
saying
biden something's wrong with biden
biden's going to be unable to keep it
together biden's going to be unable to
put together a coherent sentence
and of course joe biden did fine in the
debate against
bernie sanders now it is true that the
subject matter
because it was heavily coronavirus based
uh probably helped biden uh in in some
sense
but if you were expecting biden to be
unable to put together a sentence you
certainly were disappointed and i've
made the same prediction about the
debates with donald trump you have
people
including like don jr and others on the
right
who are pushing the biden dementia
narrative who
are claiming that joe biden is barely
going to know where he is in a debate
with donald trump and i just don't think
that's going to be the case
now in advance of this donald trump has
now started floating the idea
that maybe the reason joe biden was able
to hold it together in his one-on-one
debate with bernie sanders was that
joe biden was on some kind of drug
presumably some kind of stimulant
now what is amazing to me about this
is that this is exactly the speculation
about donald trump
the degree of projection from donald
trump and republicans
if you look at the rnc this week
accusing the democratic party
and the dnc of everything which they
have been doing
this week accusing the dnc of merely
criticizing trump during their
convention well all they've been doing
is criticizing joe biden
accusing the dnc of not talking about
policy during their convention
the republicans have not talked about
any policy during their convention
and now after years of speculation that
donald trump you know we've we've
identified
upper trump and downer trump upper trump
sometimes shows up at events
sweaty speaking in a sort of manic way
uh dilated pupils even in front of
bright
lighting sniffing uh glitching
etc and then sometimes it's a downer
trump that shows up and
you know the the sort of casual
speculation is is it amphetamines when
it's upper trump
is it benzos when it's down or trump is
it some combination of both
okay whatever now by uh trump says
he wants drug tests before the debates
because he believes
joe biden may have been on something
during his debate with bernie sanders
here's the video what nobody thought is
that he was even going to win
because he had debate performances was
so bad you know
frankly his best performance was against
bernie
we're going to call for a drug test by
the way because his best performance
was against bernie it wasn't that he was
winston churchill because he wasn't but
he
it was a normal boring debate you know
nothing
amazing happened and and we are going to
call for a drug test because there's no
way you can't do that
what do you think's been going on well i
don't know how he could have been so
incompetent
in his debate performances and then all
of a sudden be
okay against bernie i don't mean he was
good or greater i just mean he was
a normal boring debate it was nothing
you understand he got through it well
frankly i thought he
he was you know they were even more or
less right
and most people didn't think and so they
did something
they did something there was no way
because i watched his debates against
kamala
who's another one that's a beauty she's
she's
if you go by the polls she started high
and she ended low that's usually not a
good sign right as far as somebody that
you pick
but against elizabeth warren they they
ripped her
apart so uh there
there's a few different thoughts here
first of all on the facts should
candidates be drug tested before debates
i don't really think so to be perfectly
frank now
i think if you want to step back and say
we need to look at
more requirements to be president of the
united states
i think it's legally difficult the one
that for me would be a higher priority
than a drug test would be an actual
proper cognitive test than a neuro
psyche eval like
dr bandy lee talked to us about a couple
of weeks ago
but maybe the country would decide
presidents shouldn't be using drugs and
thus
presidential candidates should be tested
for drugs
the idea of a drug test before a debate
is not particularly interesting to me
but the most
interesting part of it is that it is
trump
who many have suspected of abusing
whether it's amphetamines or some other
type of upper and again it's all
speculative
but the idea that now trump is saying
biden should be tested
what i hear is projection the constant
projection from donald trump of the last
four years has trained me to think
if trump is pointing to something if
trump is raising the idea
if it occurs to trump that biden's
performance may have been enhanced
by some kind of uh stimulant or
something else it seems implicit that
trump is talking about stimulants
i immediately go to is trump thinking
about that because it applies to him
and i'm curious to hear what you think
about this speaking by the way of drugs
donald trump jr was now asked when he
was on fox and friends yesterday morning
whether his tirade speech at the
republican national convention on monday
night
was filled by cocaine and he has since
denied it now
um last night was night three of the
republican national convention but if
you think back to the first night there
were many questions raised about the
insanity of donald trump jr speech
and also the speech of his girlfriend
kimberly guilfoyle the content was of
course completely unhinged
but the delivery also raised questions
about upper use
because both don jr and kimberly
guilfoyle
seemed completely shot out of cannons
kimberly guilfoyle screaming
uncontrollably which we'll get to
don jr his eyes almost swollen
completely shut
almost like a frothing at the mouth
delivery
well donald trump jr is now denying that
his speech was fueled by cocaine and
this is one of those things where
if you're even talking about this maybe
there's a problem
here is don jr himself answering the
questions about this yesterday on fox
and friends
you were one of the keynote speakers on
the first night monday night
and speaking of the media i afterwards i
i saw that the
main concern was why were his eyes so
glassy well i guess there must have been
something with the lighting but they
started doing this
trending thing uh donald trump jr's on
cocaine and all that i said
no no you have me confused with hunter
biden
oh it was it was pretty ridiculous you
know so
when they can't attack the delivery when
they can't attack the substance
they gotta attack something just like
bette midler
and all of these woke hollywoodites last
night attacking melania
because she didn't speak english the
same way that they would well she speaks
five languages she's from a foreign
country she got up on a world stage
and knocked it out of the park but you
know what attack her
it's ridiculous it's the same as
watching the dnc attacking the rnc
because the rnc has
the gall to showcase real americans who
have benefited
for donald trump's policies who have
benefited from this administration
rather than the out-of-touch hollywood
celebrities
that they put on their never-ending zoom
call
uh of i hate america last week uh it's
truly mind-boggling how out of touch
the democrats are they don't even see it
it's asinine
notice that don jr doesn't say i've
never done cocaine or i don't do
cocaine he simply says i was not on coke
that night but hunter biden was
something about the lighting made him
look like maybe he was on coke i guess
uh and the more i think about it if i
were a public figure
and someone asked me about an interview
during an interview
about whether i was on cocaine during a
speech and if it was really bogus
i don't think i would dignify it with a
response i don't know about you i would
say
that's absolutely absurd it's being
asserted without evidence
and i i'm not even gonna dignify that
with a response
uh there's also video from before don jr
went on of him drinking
two red bulls so maybe it's just red
bull maybe it was red bull and something
else i don't know but take a look at
this
guys donald trump jr here super excited
first night of the rnc
2020 getting amped up and ready for my
speech it's gonna be awesome
now just a reminder here's one of the
most unhinged moments from don junior's
speech just so you know
this has not been sped up or in any way
you'll notice
if you're watching don junior's swollen
eyes and just a lot of other weird
details
imagine the life you want to have one
with a great job
a beautiful home a perfect family you
can have it
imagine the country you want to live in
one with true
equal opportunity where hard work pays
off and justice is served with
compassion and without partiality
you can have it imagine a world where
the evils of communism and radical
islamic terrorism
are not given a chance to spread where
heroes are celebrated and the good guys
win
you can have it that is the life
that is the country that is the world
that donald trump
and the republican party are after and
yes you
can have it because unlike joe biden and
the radical left democrats
our party is open to everyone
it starts by rejecting radicals who want
to drag us into the dark
and embracing the man who represents
a bright and beautiful future for all
and then even more outrageously here is
kimberly guilfoyle just screaming at the
top of her lungs
ladies and gentlemen leaders and
fighters for freedom and liberty and the
american dream
the best is yet to come
so if lighting is the only explanation i
want to talk to the gaffer and see how
he was able to achieve that look but
here's
here's what i really want to focus on
first of all
it's insane that this is even something
that's being discussed
fine but more importantly
isn't it really weird that when don jr
was asked about it
he doesn't deny using cocaine he says it
was the lights and hunter biden actually
does cocaine
i find that to be a really strange
reaction and then
the top level thought that i had was
i consider drug addiction to be a
medical issue it's not something we
laugh at
it's not something we make fun of and
when don jr makes this comment about
hunter biden
hunter biden has spoken about living
with drug addiction
and don jr is essentially making fun of
someone in recovery from drug addiction
and that's really the disgust the most
disgusting aspect of this so
this entire episode is another
confirmation
that money can't really by class and
that an expensive education
also doesn't guarantee empathy both
things that we probably knew before the
trump presidency
but have been made even more clear uh
but in any case
for all of you who emailed me about what
don and kimberly were on
monday night he denies that it was
cocaine
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video